want to see
Lady I was I was I was telling her I was
doing my cards and it was so funny
because they for the show I was write
cards and and I was like it says the
Garcia twins I didn't see pictures all I
stff was Garcia Twins and said Garcia
twins have been here um four times and I
was like what I was like who and you
changed your name so I didn't know it
and I was like oh the Bell is I was like
so what why the name change by the way
Hannah meet Hannah sorry you're
amazing this is like double ridiculous
Beauty I know couch it is unfair it is
unfair yes so Christmas right here I
know I like it we're all sparkly we
should do a number I'm just kidding
would it be fun if it just broke out no
but why the name change curious yeah so
Nikki and I we ended up leaving WWE and
you know WWE when you leave you don't
get to take your name with you so you
have to keep it at the ring which was
unfortunate but also for us we just
really wanted our power back we wanted
to fully own our brand and going back to
the Garcia twins it was nice it was like
going back to Our Roots it's our legal
name it's what we grew up with so it
feels really good very empowered oh look
how hot you are I know and you were
saying I was asking I was asking Hannah
in the break if they had wrestling you
had wrestling overse yeah one of one of
my best friends her son Zach and Charlie
are fully obsessed and probably would
lose their
minds I love it we've wrestled there a
lot I mean if I ever had a comeback I
mean I think a match right here would be
absolutely but if you like song and
dance she's your girl yes right good
manager yeah is it was it hard leaving
because that's been a life for y'all for
so long it was really hard it was very
Bittersweet it was one of those things
where Nikki and I it's like we miss the
ring um her and I just you know when
you're out there we're like artists you
know it's like a blank canvas it's like
it's one of those things where it's
always a part of you but like in this
book of life it was a chapter and a
chapter will always keep close to our
hearts but now we're about to walk into
a whole new decade of 40 and I love
so far 40s are so good so far yes well
you actually saw me recently I was I was
I I just that for a second you two are
40 just to hang that for a
second crazy ah okay so you just got
married so how is that life how's that
oh I got amazing yeah you know and I
think cuz we did like yeah we did
everything kind of backwards we had the
kid first we went through the pandemic
so we survived that together how it goes
we're like okay we could do life
together we've tested it for a few years
and then we got married and it's been
amazing and yeah I love him and so
that's so awesome was did I hear that
your your dad surprised you he did yeah
what did he do my dad my dad and my mom
had not been in this under the same Ro
in what over 20 years oh yeah if not
long time very long time so when he
surprised me one just seeing my dad in
Paris was hilarious but um when I heard
his voice I was like that there's no way
that's John Garcia and I look and
there's John Garcia yeah and it was
amazing and incredible I hadn't seen him
in a really long time and so to
reconnect and actually see all my family
together since we had been 15 um was
really incredible yeah really long time
um so let's talk about your new show
twin love what's this about oh so 10
identical twins come to find love and
you know it's crazy because which are
there like a plethora of that like
hanging out which are because I don't
feel like I know a lot of identical and
they both have to be single so I know it
was a total social dating experience
but then we have two identical houses
the Nikki house and the Bri house so
they don't even realize that that when
they're coming to us they think they're
going to find love together and then we
split them up because now the experiment
needs to start and that's scary for
twins like is it a little codependent
just because you grew up together yeah
and you have confidence and then think
too like you're coming in and like
you're single you want to impress and
then all a sudden we just take away that
other side of you you had to see every
not only did they get very upset but
they just kind of all like got really
small like wait what's happening
interesting but I will say what's really
incredible about the show is not only is
it a fun dating show that comes with
that is the drama and the messiness but
you see these PE these twins go on this
individual journey and they really find
their individuality which I find is a
beautiful thing because as twins we know
that's really hard sometimes cuz yeah
you guys are singulars that's what we
call you we're twins yeah but I bet you
guys can cause a whole load of trouble I
know we missed out on you we did you
said we did uh well let's take a short
break everybody be sure to watch twin
love on Prime video as well as the Nikki
and Bree show wherever you get your
podcast yall are busy ladies um cuz you
also got B again all right we'll be
right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home oh